In another world,
Gaby would be in an oddies band.
Gaby's band name would be something
that's like more like a phrase
like Panic! At The Disco.
Like “For Real?!” with a question mark.
Gaby's oddies esthetic was definitely
like razored hair pressed straight,
like the ponytail’s
just a little too straight
because it hasn't been pressed
that much.
Really colorful pants like hair on pants,
probably something ridiculous like that.
In another world,
Liz started playing pickleball
with Jimmy, but then she becomes the best
pickleball player in the world.
She's playing for New York, playing
pickleball where they have the
U.S. Open in Queens.
The team is called the Crunchers.
We're going to go green and pink.
So we take the palm tree
esthetic from L.A.,
but we're still in the East Coast,
but we still remember where we're from.
In another world, I'm thinking Sean
will be probably a superhero.
He'd have something intelligent
like mind control.
Like if I tell you in your mind
what to do,
how are you going to fight me?
You don’t want to fight that guy.
Just Diesel in a suit?
Not on your best day.
Alice needs to let go a little bit.
I feel like if she was a lead singer of
like, a punk band in Seattle
in like, the nineties,
I feel like she could really let all her
anger and all her pain go.
As an homage to Phoebe Bridgers,
the song that Alex listens to,
“I Know the End”
I think it's a great band name.
I think that Derek would like to move to
the Italian Riviera.
He would get a nice pair of Speedos
and he'd get
maybe a Vespa scooter
with pockets on the side,
and he'd fill it every day
with fresh sausages and flowers.
He would open a small café.
Everyone knows your name,
and you really can rediscover
yourself through the coffee.